most of the expensive food that I found
is very tiny
I like big amounts of plain I'll
probably spend between 50 and 60 dollars
a week I love to eat fancy foods and go
to like restaurants I wonder if
expensive food just tastes good because
you know it costs money I'm expecting
tricks golden bagel it's great let's
just try like a piece of gold say
nothing
oh this is a rich person's
interpretation of what the doughnut is
they're like oh I think it's round I
don't know let's put some gold on it
right who has extra gold all of us I'm
gonna go to the bank and just and just
cash this in okay so right off the bat I
know I'm not gonna like this cuz I'm a
little baby boy dip it in the sauce I
don't know I exit just dropped a slimy
mushroom I don't even think I need the
water it was actually pretty good I just
like this flavor I like of it I feel
like that's kind of how people describe
wasabi which I hate like a piece of skin
like ever bite but your cheek by
accident and kind of chew on it I could
meet the woman of my dreams in three
weeks and want to sweep her off her feet
and kiss her and she would taste this on
me if you don't eat that almani that
okay actual nightmare right excreting a
super fancy food as a utensil for
another super fancy food
[Music]
you ate the whole thing okay it's all
good
Cheers oh my god oh my god it's very
good are you like into fancy food now
I don't know $25,000 US dollars best
taco I've ever had was a dollar taco off
of a taco truck that had a B rating
these cannot be edible it's in the taco
rich people don't pick stuff out of
their food they eat it this is not
edible this is the fancy way this is the
fancy eating yes
tacos oh no I did that wrong I would say
the meat is really great it is so it's
like cartoonishly it's like wiping your
butt with money you know I would do that
though it was interesting I just feel
like I wouldn't stay a rich person if I
kept you miss every day very good point
you have a pile of cash to nurse that
doughnut I was like I ate $50 worth no
it take it away it was made of things
that I wouldn't ever think to eat like
the eggs of a fish we are gold yeah like
you know it would have been good the
fish
[Music]